Speaker 1: I want to look at a clip from I
believe it's yesterday's Joe Rogan program,
Joe Rogan interviewed a friend of our show.
Josh zaps very good guy.
I've been on his show doesn't mean Josh and
I agree on everything, but I've always known
him to be a good guy.
Josh appeared with Joe Rogan and the topic
came up of myocarditis risk for young men
from the COVID vaccines.
Important topic.
Joe Rogan was presented with the evidence
that the risk of myocarditis from having COVID
is significantly higher than the risk of myocarditis
from the vaccine.
In both cases, most everybody recovers.
No problem, but the risk of myocarditis is
higher if you get COVID than if you get the
vaccine in real time, you will see really
disappointing goal post moving and techniques
from Joe Rogan that are really typical.
Sadly, of the people that email me and are
clearly set in their ways and don't want to
have their minds changed.
So let's take a look at the conversation.
This is this is interesting.
It's also really sad
Speaker 2: pointing myocarditis more common
after COVID 19 infection than vaccination.
But is this what?
Speaker 1: Oh, so first.
Now here's a study.
The study already says myocarditis is more
common from COVID than from the vaccine, so
that already goes against what Joe Rogan has
been told.
And I'll show you part of where he got it.
Speaker 2: Children, uh, yeah.
We're talking about young men.
Speaker 1: So Rogan now says, Well, I'm really
I'm talking about it within young people.
Speaker 2: Only boys aged under 30 after this,
this one says here.
Speaker 1: So as you can see, the study as
as Jamie points out, includes up to age 30
and that includes younger and that includes
up to all the way up to 30
Speaker 2: with children is the issue.
Speaker 1: Well, now Brogan says, I'm only
concerned about children here.
Speaker 2: We're talking about 15 year olds.
Well, we're talking about young children.
So yes, all of the 17 12 to 17 more like the
myocarditis with three months of catching
COVID at a rate of 450 cases per million infection,
this compares to 67 cases of myocarditis per
million josh.
Speaker 1: The same points out correctly.
Look at the 12 to 17 age group.
Is that young enough, Joe?
Even among 12 to 17, your risk of getting
myocarditis from COVID is about eight times
higher than from the vaccine
Speaker 2: time following her second dose
of Pfizer.
Yes, so you're about eight times likelier
to get myocarditis from getting COVID than
from getting the vaccine.
That's interesting.
That is not what I've read before, but also
it's like, well, even when we're reading these
things, it's like, What are we getting this
from?
Well, this is
Speaker 1: a peer reviewed study, and there's
numerous peer reviewed studies that have been
done on this.
So.
So notice the goalposts shifting.
It's OK now there is a claim that the risk
is actually higher of myocarditis from COVID
than from vaccines.
But can we really trust what we're reading?
Well, actually, we can
Speaker 2: promote Verizon forward, but even
from the various reports, when they report
this stuff, it's like the amount of people
that report them, like it's the underreporting.
Speaker 1: So now there's a new thing, which
is Rogan says, even if you consider Veirs,
which is not even verified, Rogan says stuff
is being underreported.
So this study is based on under-reporting
to Veirs when we know the real issue with
theirs is actually over reporting completely
unconfirmed reporting.
Notice the goalposts shifting that takes place
Speaker 2: depending upon who you ask and
what it is.
It's either one percent under OK.
Speaker 1: So this is unfortunately, this
is what happens a lot of times when you when
you have these types of conversations with
people.
Now, I had this conversation not long ago.
I have a family member who works in pediatrics,
and I said before I got my third dose, you
know, I'm kind of freaked out because now
when you sign up for your third, like I'm
the most pro vaccine person.
When I signed up for my third dose, it had
me.
I understand it said, Do you understand that
there is a risk of myocarditis?
And it just freaked me out and the person
I was talking to said, Yeah, but David, remember
the risk to people.
Your age from COVID of myocarditis is higher
than from the vaccine.
And here studies that we've been looking at
and I looked at it and said, Oh, you're absolutely
right.
Right.
That makes sense.
And a lot of this goes back to that Peter
McCullough appearance with Joe Rogan, where
McCullough was talking about vaccine induced
myocarditis and did not mention, by the way,
the risk of COVID induced myocarditis is dramatically
higher than from the vaccine.
So I wish that Joe Rogan had received this
information differently.
Really nice job by Josh Zaps, and as I've
said before, I welcome any opportunity to
go back on and talk to Rogen about exactly
this issue.